[Music]
in the year 1900 there were 1.6 billion
people on earth by the year 2000 that
number had skyrocketed to 6 point 1
billion this astounding rate of growth
has slowed but the trend is still
heading dramatically upward world
population is expected to pass 7 billion
in late October and 9 billion by 2050
and the latest UN projections put it at
roughly 10 billion in 2100 but in truth
no one knows exactly how high population
will grow or when it might flatline all
population projections are uncertain as
they are entirely dependent on
assumptions about the future in that
sense these numbers can be considered
best scientific guesses not destiny
moreover the further out one looks the
cloudier these projections become still
they offer a window into an otherwise
unknown future
over the next few minutes we're going to
guide you through some of these
projections showing you past trends in
population a modern-day snapshot and the
outlook for coming decades
the world has never seen anything like
the population explosion of the past
century four billion people have been
added to the planet since 1950 and the
time it takes to add 1 billion people
has dropped just 13 years
the United Nations predicts that world
population could reach nine point three
billion by 2050 region by region however
the rate of population growth varies
substantially less developed countries
are growing rapidly while more developed
countries are growing slowly if at all
the UN has forecasted population out to
the year 2100
but those projections are even more
uncertain than those for 2050 the medium
variant most commonly used assumes the
average woman in 2100 will have two
children if she had half a child more or
less the picture would change
dramatically maintaining the current
fertility rate would have the most
erratic effect of all
looking back much of the population
growth of the past 50 years is due to
spectacular gains and life expectancy in
developing countries reflecting advances
in public health and medicine
the period of most rapid population
growth is behind us the growth rate has
declined since its peak from 1965 to
1970 falling by roughly half in 40 years
as women have had fewer children in the
last 50 years the global fertility rate
has dropped from 5 to 2.5 and the
average woman in developing countries
excluding China now has 3 children down
from 6
[Music]
but that downward trend in fertility
masks sharp regional differences since
1970 Asia and Latin America have seen
the steepest drops while in sub-saharan
Africa fertility remains high
[Music]
in general high fertility rates are
associated with poverty and low levels
of educational attainment for girls
what is the ideal number of children and
a family let's take a look at responses
to that question from women around the
world
[Music]
virtually all population growth from now
until 2050 will occur in developing
countries for the largest growth
concentrated in the poorest countries of
the world because of sub-saharan
Africa's high fertility rate the fastest
growth will occur there but despite a
slower growth rate Asia largely India
and China will still account for the
bulk of the world's population in 2050
the age distribution within a society
also varies by region these are
population pyramids also known as age
structure diagrams each bar represents
an age increment from the youngest at
the bottom to the oldest at the top and
the overall shape illustrates the age
distribution within a given population
in developing countries the large
proportion of young people indicated by
a robust pyramid shape ensures rapid
population growth but the aging
population in more developed countries
with few future parents spells little or
no growth to demonstrate this compare
today's young and aging populations in
sub-saharan Africa and Europe
by the year 2050 the population of
developing countries will far outstrip
the population of developed countries
[Music]
a look at Nigeria and Japan today
suggests what's ahead given Nigeria's
high birthrate and large number of women
of childbearing age its population is
expected to more than double by 2050 the
population of Japan however is expected
to decline
if these general trends continue into
the year 2050 developed countries will
not have enough workers to support the
higher costs of their aging populations
developing countries with young
populations will not have enough jobs
what's more international migration is
set to increase in a year 2050 more and
more people will be living in cities and
towns with the fastest rate of
urbanization occurring in less developed
countries
this amplified urbanization in less
developed countries is reflected by the
projected change in rankings of the most
populous cities from 1975 to 2025
the infographics you've seen here were
produced as part of a special issue of
science magazine all about population
all of this information and more can be
found on the science website
[Applause]
[Music]